Свідомо обрати професію у 15-17 років – непросте завдання
А особливо тоді, коли близькі не підтримують вибір
Уявімо ситуацію. Молодий хлопець цікавиться модними зачісками
та мріє стати барбером
Але цю професію можна отримати не в університеті,
а в звичайному профтехучилищі
І тут виникає низка перепон
Батьки наполягають на вступі до університету та отриманні
більш престижної, на їхню думку, професії
А друзі насміхаються над вибором, бо вона “не чоловіча”
Після такого тиску чи матиме бажання дитина стати перукарем?
Думаю, навряд
Ще один поширений приклад – коли батьки за будь яку ціну
намагаються  продовжувати родинну справу
“Усі в родині були лікарями, тож і ти маєш бути” або
“Ми побудували свій бізнес з нуля, тобто ти маєш його продовжувати”
Знайомі ситуації?
Вирішити їх треба із найменшими травмами для усіх сторін
Врахуйте, що сучасний світ дуже мінливий, тож ваша дитина
може опанувати ще кілька професій
Це не означатиме невдачу чи помилку, це –
частина нормальної кар'єрної траєкторії
Розібратися в ситуації, пройти профорієнтаційне дослідження
може допомогти шкільний психолог або соціальний педагог
Не бійтесь довіряти своїм дітям,
і нехай вони перетворять талант на справжню професію